90 féminicide ont eu lieu en 2020 146 en
2019 dans les yvelines les policiers et
gendarmes sont mobilisés pour mieux
accueillir et orienter les victimes de
violences conjugales
il propose des journées de
sensibilisation cette journée de
sensibilisation elle s'adresse aux
policiers municipaux du département des
yvelines
sur la base du volontariat bien
évidemment ça permet de leur faire
comprendre ce que sont les violences
conjugales
le mécanisme et surtout leur donner des
outils derrière pour mieux accueillir
les victimes de violence organisée
conjointement par la police la
gendarmerie et la préfecture ces
formations sont nécessaires c'est
indispensable parce que nos collègues
des polices municipales sont souvent
confrontés avant nous j'ai envie de dire
avant le dépôt de plaintes par exemple à
ses victimes
donc il faut absolument qu'ils
comprennent ce qui est une victime
comment elle peut être amenée à réagir
et comment on accueille et comment on
oriente re la journée se déroule en
trois temps
la matinée est consacrée à la
connaissance de ce qu'est l'emprise
mentale et le stress post traumatique
ensuite les policiers apprennent à mieux
réagir sur le terrain et l'après midi un
échange avec une association est
organisé et les policiers municipaux
sont très demandeurs pense que c'est
important il faut te il faut être prêt à
telle écoute sur toutes les différentes
missions et donc ses missions où il ya
une méconnaissance je pense ceux des
forces de l'ordre pour avoir par rapport
à tout ça et surtout d'état les coudes
par rapport à ces problèmes
d'après l'audit sur l'accueil en
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violence 90% des
victimes se dit satisfaite de l'accueil
des résultats encourageants mais qui
peuvent être améliorées et puissent
d'amélioration ces deux formes et former
former informer de manière à ce que tous
nos collègues qu'ils soient
police/gendarmerie municipale etc
connaissent ce phénomène ce phénomène et
les particularités de ce phénomène et
toutes les personnes qui travaillent en
police municipale dans les yvelines
peuvent participer à ces journées de
sensibilisation